vamos a la revista de prensa como harta
Moya Marta Buen día para usted Hola
Ángela Buenos días y empezamos como uno
hablando de uno de los temas de la
agenda internacional que más espacio
ocupa en las últimas dos semanas y es
Sudán donde se han intensificado las
evacuaciones mientras que los combates
continúan en jartum esto lo reflejan
medios como el yacira y como la agencia
de noticias raiters Así es Ángela
recordemos no todo esto empezó el 15 de
abril en el estallido de los combates
entre el ejército liderado por el
general y el grupo paramilitar fuerzas
de acción rápida liderado por Mohamed
happdam dugalo ambos eran aliados hasta
2021 cuando dieron un golpe de estado
juntos y después las tensiones entre
ambos se intensificaron cuando el grupo
paramilitar pidió integrarse en el
ejército estos enfrentamientos que ya
tienen dos semanas dejan al menos 420
civiles muertos más de 3.700 heridos
además los udaneses que viven en la
capital están atrapados en sus hogares
muchos sin acceso a agua o alimentos por
ello en los países extranjeros han
agilizado esas evacuaciones en las
últimas 48 horas cuando esos combates
han bajado algo de intensidad es al
jazzira reporta que al menos una
veintena de países han llevado a cabo
misiones de evacuación o están
pendientes de hacerlo en las próximas
horas desde Canadá hasta Corea del Sur
Estados Unidos Francia España Canadá por
ejemplo ha dicho que va a tener a sus
diplomáticos en un lugar seguro hasta
que baje las tensiones en Sudán Francia
ha trasladado varios aviones a shibuty
evacuaciones también por mar y por aire
trasladados por el por Sudán a 800
kilómetros más o menos de la capital
incluso con barcos trasladados a Arabia
saudite este lunes a primera hora
también ha llegado el primer avión a
Berlín de ciudadanos alemanes y en total
como en los informativos al menos 1000
personas de la Unión Europea ya han sido
evacuadas y no tenemos sin embargo
muchos detalles de cuantos de cada
nacionalidad Pero bueno dos semanas de
conflicto esto no parece demostrar un
final Marta Así que le voy a pedir que
cambiemos de tema hoy se cumple un año
desde que el presidente de Francia de
Manuel macron asumió El Poder por
segunda vez un año bien complicado y las
portadas francesas lo reflejan como es
normal digamos Así es Ángela y hemos
destacado tres portadas de este lunes de
la prensa francesa vamos a empezar Por
lemont que titula un año después de su
reelección macron aislado enfrenta el
resentimiento del país además en el
subtítulo de la portada de lemont se
destaca que la crisis de la Reforma de
las pensiones acabó de aislar al jefe de
estado que también ha tenido una gran
distancia y dentro del ejecutivo que
lidera Elizabeth born también destacamos
el titular y la portada de la qua que es
bastante más amable con macron y titu
macronistas a pesar de todo un año
después de la reelección el presidente
puede contar todavía con el apoyo de un
cuarto de los franceses Claro que pasa
con las otras tres cuartas partes que
están en su contra no quizá un poco
entusiasta este titular de la croa y
también destacamos la portada de
Liberación en la que vemos a macron
haciendo equilibrios en el mango de una
olla y titula Liberación un año después
de la reelección huele a quemado tres
meses después de el inicio de las
protestas por la reforma de las
pensiones a la cola en las encuestas y
sin una mayoría Clara en la asamblea
legislativa macron intenta mantener el
control hemos destacado también una
viñeta de liberación Que firma coco que
en la que se vea macron en esa misma
olla navegando en un lodazal y dice algo
como todavía quedan cuatro años
que es cuando están previstas que se
celebren las próximas elecciones y no
está claro Cómo llegar a cabo su agenda
legislativa Marta así es nuevamente a
otra noticia importante porque sigue
llamando mucho la atención internacional
a la detención de un periodista de
Walter journal Ahora son de trescientos
ex corresponsales de Moscú Quienes se
han unido para pedir su Liberación lo
dice the Guardian y también habla del
tema de Moscú Times sí Ángela recordemos
Iván periodista de The wallsted journal
fue detenido el pasado 29 de marzo y
acusado por espionajes el primer
periodista estadounidense detenido bajo
estas condiciones desde el final de la
Guerra Fría
unos cargos por los que se ha declarado
inocente y que Rusia dice que fue
pillado con las manos en la masa
mientras intentaba conseguir documentos
clasificados ahora colegas de 22 países
ex corresponsales en Moscú han firmado
una un memorando una carta dedicada al
ministro de exteriores acerca por la que
piden que se libere al periodista
gerskovic dice que con su detención y
cargos que enfrenta da una señal Rusia
peligrosa e inquietante sobre la actitud
del gobierno del kremling hacia los
medios de comunicación además dicen
sentirse consternados y conmocionados
por la detención de su compañero y dicen
que su trayectoria le avala Por otra
parte el Times dice que 22 periodistas
rusos están actualmente en prisión por
ejercer la profesión y que Rusia se ha
convertido en uno de los países más
peligrosos para ejercer el periodismo
esta cifra podría aumentar con las leyes
de censura rusa y además dice que la
mayoría de estos periodistas
encarcelados pertenecen a regiones rusas
y por tanto sus casos no son tan
mediáticos ahora la última noticia es
otro Matiz que tiene que ver con la
Guerra de Ucrania es curioso Además
porque el hijo de un alto funcionario
ruso participó al parecer en la Guerra
de Ucrania y bajo instrucciones del
grupo Wagner si Ángela nos referimos a
Nicolás el hijo
portavoz del kremlin Es raro que un
familiar de un alto funcionario del
gobierno participe en activo en un
conflicto según él mismo declaró en una
entrevista un medio ruso que pidió al
jefe del grupo paramilitar Wagner
alistarse como artillero para combatir
en Ucrania durante seis meses lo hizo
bajo un nombre bueno falso para proteger
su identidad y dice que su padre está
muy orgulloso de él por haber combatido
en la guerra en Ucrania pues Marta Hemos
llegado ya al final de la sección por el
día de hoy a usted Gracias Muchas
gracias Ángela